[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT ELLIS: My
name is Scott Ellis.
I'm a product manager
here at Google
working on privacy,
security-related technology.
And we're going to talk a
little bit about that today.
And just to start, did anybody
here attend today's keynote
this morning?
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about some of the stuff that
was announced there today.
And this is a picture I took
from the back of the room.
We talked a little bit
about sensitive data
and different tools that
we have to handle it,
to manage it and
process that data.
And so we'll talk a little
bit about that today,
but first what I
want to cover here
is really talking about data and
collaboration in the modern era
and what we're doing today,
some of the trends we're seeing,
and specifically talk
about some of the tools
that we have on our
Cloud platform in G Suite
and on our production
GCP platform,
and then give a little bit of
background on sensitive data,
on personally
identifiable information.
And then the heart
of the talk is really
to welcome some of our friends
here from the University
of Chicago to talk
a little bit deeper
about data science,
de-identification, and some
of the challenges they face
and some of the opportunities
that they see.
So just a few trends.
When we look at
data now, these are
things I picked out that I
think are really kind of driving
a lot of what we're doing.
So first, we have a lot
more real-time interaction
with our users, with
customers, and with devices.
So this is, again, data
coming in, streaming in,
a lot of back-and-forth
interaction with users.
It's very fast,
very data driven.
And this is creating a lot
of larger, richer data sets.
And I use that word
"richer" because we all
see these large data
sets and we think
that we can extract out
information from them,
like just valuable information,
learn more about how
our customers or
users are interacting,
predict things that they
might do, and, in some cases,
even cope with
life-saving predictions
and life-saving things that
we can learn from that.
And as part of that,
as it's real-time
and we're getting larger
and larger data sets,
we also want to make
faster decisions.
So we want to be able
to look at this data,
and we want to act
on it very quickly.
We don't want to take
months to figure out
what we should have done, if we
need to interact with somebody
in seconds or minutes.
So we need to be both
dealing with larger data sets
and making faster decisions.
And when we talk
about collaboration,
that just means we need
streamlined collaboration.
We need to be able to
talk to each other back
and forth in real time
or near real time.
We need to be able
to just add somebody
in to a document or
share something with them
and have it just be a
seamless experience.
And, again, some of that
data that we're talking about
is sensitive.
So it's not all just bits.
Some of this stuff is very
sensitive information,
specifically sensitive
information about people
that we do need to protect.
So securing this
data is crucial.
We spend a lot of time looking
across the board of how
we secure data, things like
two factor authentication,
setting the right
access control,
audit logging for when
people go in and access data,
reviewing those audits--
so generating logs
and auditing them--
encrypting data, and a
whole bunch of other things
that we do.
And in fact, we spend a lot
of time, a lot of effort
in securing data
to mitigate risk.
But sometimes at some
point, you actually
want to do something
with your data.
You want to open it up.
In the last talk, if any
of you saw that with Joe,
that you'd want to use a key.
You might actually
open the vault
and let people in and do
something with your data.
That's kind of the idea here.
And once you do that, the
data itself can be a risk.
So once you do
something, you need
to be aware of who
you're sharing it with,
what you're doing,
and, in some cases,
take action to reduce that
risk in the actual data.
So let's go through an
example with Sheets.
So Google Sheets is a very--
it's a spreadsheet
app on G Suite that
has built in a lot
of-- it was built
from the ground up with a
lot of collaboration in mind.
So here's just an example.
I've got a sheet here.
You can see a column.
We're talking about
customer satisfaction.
One of these customers
has low satisfaction.
And I'm looking here,
and I want to know why.
So I want to ping in Janet,
who is a vendor that we work
with from another
company, and ask
them to go in and
figure out, why
is this customer not satisfied?
Why is their customer
satisfaction low?
Maybe they want to contact
them and figure this out.
So I just simply go in here.
I plus them in, put a plus
sign, put their name, ask them
a question, click Go.
Very simple, very easy.
This solves that
streamlined case.
It's very easy to get
in here and do this.
But let's zoom out a little bit.
So we have fast,
easy collaboration,
but let's zoom out.
What we didn't notice
is that in column F,
we had an open-note comment
field that was stuck in here.
And in one of these
comments, somebody
decided to write some
sensitive information.
So this was not my
intent to share this.
I was trying to focus on
this other column-- in fact,
another row.
But as soon as I
share this with Janet,
she's going to see
the whole spreadsheet.
So how would we
mitigate something
like this in a corporate app?
Well, I'll go through an
example of what we have.
So in G Suite, we offer
something called Data Loss
Prevention where you can
set very simple policies
around this.
And this policy is really geared
around three main things--
triggers, conditions,
and actions.
So in this case, we look at
something like a trigger.
I'm going to share
this data with somebody
outside of my domain.
The condition is I want to look
for some sensitive information.
In this case, we're going
to look for social security
numbers, driver's license
numbers, and credit card
numbers.
And then I want to
take some action.
So in this case,
I'd probably want
to block sharing, maybe notify
an admin, things like that.
So if we go back to that, and
as soon as I click Comment here,
what's actually happening
in the background is Sheets
will look at this
and say, I need
to go add Janet to this doc.
She needs permissions
to view it.
I need to send her an email
to go click and view it.
But with DLP, we
will first check
to see if there's an issue
with that kind of action
and provide some sort of warning
or block the actual sharing.
In this case, document contains
a social security number,
and so we can't
share it externally.
And that's pretty
straightforward.
DLP helps organizations
manage their data,
and it can help meet legal,
regulatory, compliance,
contractual obligations.
And it's a pretty standard
operating feature.
But what about production
and development environment?
So this was an issue that
at Google, we face a lot.
We use G Suite.
We love it.
But we have a huge
production environment,
and we seamlessly go
back and forth from one
to the other in a lot of cases.
And so for us, we were
very concerned about,
what about when you're
developing an app?
What about when you're
dealing with large-scale data
that we call kind of
like production data,
data that's coming
out of our systems,
out of our applications, out
of our day-to-day business?
And so this morning, we
talked about a new offering
that we have called the
Data Loss Prevention API.
What this really
is is we're taking
a lot of that
functionality that you
get to in G Suite going through
a policy and a rules engine
and providing that
capability as an API
directly into the
Cloud platform.
And the idea here
is that you can now
build this into your own apps.
You can take the
same kind of logic
that we built into Gmail
and Drive and Sheets
and build it into your own
applications or workflows.
And I'll show a
few examples here.
So, again, it's the
same engine that we've
built Gmail and Drive on
and giving you capabilities
like to be able to classify your
data, redact sensitive data,
efficiently manage
sensitive data.
So, again, you may just not
even know what you have.
You have a lot of
information coming in.
You've got different
assets, and you just
want to classify them and
manage them appropriately.
And one of the things that
we think this really does
is unlocks some
more of the cloud.
There's things that
you're not doing today
that you could be doing.
And by having a little bit
more insight on your data,
we think that it can open
up more of the cloud.
So let's go to an example.
So we showed something in
the keynote this morning.
We showed a live demo app
of a customer support chat.
So I'm going to kind of walk
through that use case here.
So imagine you have this
customer support app.
And in there, you have
a chat transcript.
And you chat.
In this case, you've had
a customer interaction.
And at the very end, maybe you
want to email a copy of that
to the customer.
So you have a simple
action in your app.
You click Email
Copy to Customer.
But in this case, we've
detected that there's
sensitive information
in there, and you
may want to prompt
the user again
in a custom built app
the same kind of way
that we prompted
someone in Sheets.
So in this case,
we've warned them
that there is a credit card
number, a social security
number, and a phone number.
And so maybe you don't want
email this to a customer.
That doesn't show a
very good best practice.
So your option could
be just don't do it,
or maybe you want to go in
and redact that stuff out.
So the customer still gets the
meaning behind the transcript,
but you're not revealing their
credit card number to their AOL
account or wherever it's going.
And another example--
but now let's
you have that chat transcript,
and you've probably
got millions of these.
And so you take that
one chat transcript.
You export all of them.
And you want to do
something with it.
You want to maybe load it up
to bigger analytics, machine
learning, natural
language processing.
And you kind of want to
analyze what kind of trends
do I see in my free text
customer support chat.
So to do that, first you
might want to redact it.
So again, similar
concept-- go in,
strip out everything
that's in there,
and then send it into something
like analytics or machine
learning.
So, again, this is just a
safer way to kind of unlock
more usage in the cloud.
And so the idea
here again is you've
got your raw data
sitting somewhere
in a production environment.
Maybe it's just sitting on GCS.
Maybe it's loaded
up into BigQuery.
Maybe it's just hidden in some
app that you have access to
and you need to
extract it out, and you
want to get it over here, in
to do higher level analytics,
machine learning, maybe
just app development.
So think about wanting
to have test data.
You want to run
through the UI and see
what it would look like.
You maybe have debug
logs that are coming out,
and you want to analyze
those in a development
environment, things like that.
Or you want to improve
how you share this data.
So you're already
doing secure sharing
with data where you
lock down the ACLs
and make sure the right
people have access.
But again, maybe they don't
need to see everything.
Maybe the people
doing analysis only
need to see the bulk content
but not the sensitive bits.
And that's where, again,
using an API like ours,
you'd look for the
sensitive data,
go in, redact it, and then again
enable those same use cases.
So try it out.
So you can go to this site to
find out more about this API.
We also have a demo
on it that you can
go in and start typing on here.
And just type stuff in,
play around with it,
see what it detects.
As you type, you'll see things
filter in at the bottom.
In this case, I've just
given a couple sample things.
And you see at the
bottom, it starts
to come out with, hey,
here's what we found.
We're kind of confident.
We have a certain likelihood
of confidence level here.
And you start to get an idea of
what you might see in the API
as well, things like offsets,
where this data's found,
things like that.
And I'm going to go through and
show you an actual demo here.
If we just get out of
here-- and this is just
a very, very simple demo we
built, a demo on App Engine
going in and calling this API.
So in this case, what we've done
is built a simple feedback web
page.
So here, a customer could
go in, type something.
I'm going to go ahead--
and let's see here--
and just type in, please
[INAUDIBLE] my credit card.
And this is a valid card.
It's a published test card.
And it's important that it's
valid for a couple of reasons
I'll go over.
So I'm going to submit that.
Thank you for submitting it.
And then we're going to go
into an admin view here.
And we're just going
to see an admin view.
So this might be something--
again, a customer went in,
submitted something
maybe they shouldn't
have put in a feedback form.
So your default
admin view would be,
let's just show the
information but redact out
the sensitive information here.
And so what we've built
here is two simple views
calling in the API.
In this case, we decided to
store the actual raw data
but not display it to
the user by default. So
what we see here is just
a bunch of asterisks
replaced anytime we saw a PII.
Now, if a user, if an
admin needs to see that,
that can be a role-based choice.
We have a button here
that says, show PII, where
you can click it
and you'll start
to see the actual underlying
PII that's in there.
And again, that's just what
we decided to do in this app.
You might want to generate extra
audit logging for somebody who
does reveal that or just
restrict it completely
to certain people that can
handle that level of detail.
But just a very simple app
to show the point here.
And let's see.
Let's get back.
And let's just walk
through what we did.
So, again, we took something,
a very simple feedback order
form.
We sent information in.
We showed how you can
basically build a view where
that information is
redacted live shown
to the user with
asterisks in this case,
and give them the ability to
click and show the actual PII.
And now I'm going to show you
a little bit of what that looks
like using a REST API call.
So in the back end, this is what
a simple call would look like.
And it's in a JSON format.
So for developers, you'll
be able understand this.
But even if you
can't, you can almost
read this like just
human text, right?
I have an item here.
It's got a value.
And you can see this might
be what a customer might
send in his feedback.
"My order did not go through."
And then we want to look
for certain things here.
So this is similar to that
policy we saw out in Sheets.
I want to look for credit
cards, social security
cards, and email addresses.
Click Send, and you'll
get a response like this.
So in this case, we
looked for three things,
but we only found one of them.
And we give a lot
of detail here.
So we've said include the quote,
show what kind of likelihood
we have, and tell me
where you found it.
In a string of text,
it's a simple offset.
So that's how simple
it is, just even
using RESTful API calls just
to send data in, send data out.
We also have options
to do redaction.
We also support images.
You can do RESTful
calls just based--
kind of encoding the base-64,
the image, and send it in.
It's that simple.
And so how this might be
used, so we've kind of now
zoomed out on this
app that we built.
And we said, OK, so we have
an app built on App Engine.
Just maybe some front
end that we have here.
And this is the
feedback part of it.
So what we showed today was
basically taking this API
and building it in at
the app level where
you can do classification and
redaction in line, in the app,
make it a functional
part of your application.
But you could also,
in the back end,
do it when you're
working with your data.
In this case, we
looked at building it
into a Cloud Dataflow pipeline
before it gets into BigQuery.
We wanted to go in
and batch in massive--
like remove the PII
before we hit BigQuery.
But you could also
use this as a tool
to just understand
your data and then
set IAM rules appropriately.
So you maybe just
have a dynamic thing
that's scanning every week,
every month, every day.
And as soon as you
see something that
is classified as, let's say,
having certain sensitive data,
you lock it down
with an IAM rule
where only certain people that
are qualified can see that.
So there's a lot of ways
that you can weave this
in into your workflow.
So now I'm going
to go a little bit
and give a little
bit of background
on sensitive data and PII.
And then we will welcome our
friends up on stage as well.
And so what we've
covered today is
we've talked a lot about finding
sensitive data, specifically
identifiable data or what's
often called personally
identifiable information, PII.
You'll sometimes see the word
"SPII" for Sensitive Personally
Identifiable Information.
You'll see the word "PHI,"
which people in the health world
know exactly what that means--
Protected Health Information.
I've been in a
lot of rooms where
people think it means
personal health information
or something like that.
But really what it is
is it's information
protected under HIPAA.
And it breaks into two parts.
And the last talk
really covered this,
but it has to be
protected under HIPAA.
You have to be coming
from a covered entity.
But it also means that it's
data that is identifiable.
And so it does have some
overlap with just identifiers
and personally
identifiable information.
So some of these are
pretty obvious if you
look at this-- names, social
security numbers, passport
numbers, telephone
numbers, various things
that you can find with our API.
And it also talks
about some things
that are trickier to find.
And we're going to go into
a little bit of background
about what those are and
other things that you
can do to kind of handle that.
But one is highlighted
here in blue
is persistent static
identifier, something
that is not well-defined but
maybe identifies a small group
or a single individual.
So let's go take a look at
what classification looks like
or what are the
things that we do when
we're classifying this data.
So we'll go with a
very simple example.
Again, this is my credit card
followed by a string of digits.
So what we look at here
is a bunch of clues.
We can look at things
like structure.
I mean, this looks
like a credit card.
It has dashes between
every four digits.
We also have some algorithms
that can go and actually check
this number.
And it's called a checksum
in case of credit cards,
where it looks at
the number itself
and validates that it's real.
So if you put just 16
digit numbers with dashes,
that doesn't mean
it's a credit card.
In this case, we
can check that it
is a real credit card or at
least passes the test for one.
We also can look
at context clues.
In this case, it's pretty clear
that this is a credit card.
There's context saying it.
There's format saying it.
And there's some
math effectively
analyzing this and saying it.
And so what do we do with that?
So we showed today one way is
to just simply redact it out.
Other things you
can do is once you
know where it is, you
can go in and do things
like hashing or tokenization.
So in this case, we're showing
just sort of a random hash.
And we purposely made one
that doesn't look very pretty,
but that's fine.
It's a hash, the idea
being that every time I
see a certain
credit card, maybe I
want to generate the same hash.
That opens up a lot of
opportunities for trend
analysis and analytics.
But you can also do things like
format-preserving encryption
and format-preserving tokens.
So in this case, I've generated
something that kind of looks
and acts like a credit
card, but it isn't.
It's a token that
represents the credit card.
This is important if you were
really strict on the format
that you have, if
you're using it in a UI
where you want to
display something
and you want the
end user to see it
as it would be whereas
displaying the middle one
would look kind of off.
It might look like
a bug to them.
So there's a lot of
techniques for obfuscating
this kind of data.
The first step is go find it.
But there's some
challenges there.
So we're going to talk
about one of the challenges
here is names.
So here's a very simple example,
and I'm looking at a case
where the stuff
in green, you have
green boxes around the stuff
we found and we classified.
And we missed something here.
So we missed the
last name of Zhang.
So if were to use a
redaction in this,
very straightforward--
take all the stuff
we found and put Xs there.
That works, except for
what we've actually done
is very obviously highlighted
the thing we missed.
So anyone looking
at this that sees
Xs anytime they see a
name knows we found it,
knows we redacted it.
So when you see a
random name in there
that a human can pick out, they
kind of know you missed it.
It probably means
it's the real thing.
So there's other options here.
So NIST talked a
little bit about this.
And it's a common thing
of basically hiding
in plain sight.
But it's the idea of using
surrogate replacements
or realistic surrogate
replacements.
So instead of Xs,
we use other names.
So you could go in
here, for example.
Take the same example.
and now we're going to
replace "Janet" with "Cindy."
And we're going to replace
"Smith" with "Roberts."
And we're going to
leave this thing
we missed because,
again, we didn't catch it
so we can't change it.
And now in the final output,
we still missed Zhang,
but it's harder to find out.
It's harder to see
that we missed it.
Again, it's not foolproof.
There are [? attacks. ?]
You can look at this.
But it's things
like this that you
can do to reduce the risk
of somebody looking at this
and obviously finding
the information
that you didn't
want them to find.
So this is an example of
hiding in plain sight.
And, again, pointing
it out here,
this is kind of like
tokenizing, what
we showed with the credit card.
What we're really doing is
we're using a realistic name
as a replacement there.
And we've done it, in
this case, with integrity
where "Janet" is replaced
with "Cindy" in all cases.
A very simple example
here, but if did
want to know that this is the
same name, you can do that.
And now we'll just look
at one last concept
here that kind of touches
on that persistent static
identifier.
And it's the concept
of k-anonymity.
And I'll do a very
rough example of this,
but imagine you've
stripped out all
of the sensitive
information that you think
is in your dataset.
You stripped down credit cards,
social security cards, maybe
even names.
You've got it really down.
But what you have
is you have a data
set with some
sensitive information.
Let's just say it's salary
information or something
about employees.
In this case, let's
say it's Googlers.
And you wanted to do some
analysis on job titles.
So what you want to do is
keep their job title in,
look at maybe salaries
and promotions and things
that could be sensitive,
and do some analysis on it.
Well, in this case, it seems
pretty straightforward,
but an obvious problem here is
something like CEO of Google.
It's not hard for anyone in
this room to guess who that is.
Today, it would be one person.
If you looked over
a 10-year period,
it's still down to three
people pretty much.
So that's an outlier.
That's something
that we wouldn't
have thought of as
a unique identifier,
but it pretty much is.
Software engineer, not so much.
But you can imagine there's
a whole spectrum here.
So there's a whole
spectrum of what we
call these high-risk outliers.
In our case at Google, we have
a lot of different engineering
titles.
There's software engineer.
There's senior
software engineer.
There's distinguished engineer.
There's things like
Google Fellows.
All of these things are
different job titles,
and some of them are relatively
unique, relatively rare,
and which fall into a
high-risk outlier group.
So those are the kind
of things where you
can do distribution analysis.
And what k-anonymity does
is looks at how many people
group into that
particular attribute.
So in a simple way,
software engineer,
in this small example,
would have a k of four.
There's four people in
it just in this sample.
And CEO of Google
has a k of one.
So if you were to
think of a threshold
that you'd want to set--
again, this is a
very small data size,
but you'd want your
threshold maybe
to be two or three in
this small example.
But in a larger
dataset, you might
be looking at setting a
threshold of 10, 20, 100,
1,000, really depending
on the use case
and how sensitive
that information is.
So this is, again, just one
more kind of a little bit more
advanced concept,
but an important one
to consider when you're
looking at sensitive data.
So what we've covered
here, again, is some tools
that we have to
help you in G Suite,
and specifically, taking
some of those tools
and giving the power to you to
weave them into your own apps,
weave them into your own
workflows, your own pipelines.
You can find out more
about this again online,
cloud.google.com/dlp.
And now what I'd like to do
is welcome some of our friends
up on stage, Michael and Sam
from University of Chicago,
to talk a little bit more
about the challenges.
So I've covered
some of the basics,
but what we really
want to hear from
is real data scientists
who face this challenge
and want to do real
things with data
and face this issue with
sensitive information and data
identification.
And so I'm going to
hand it off to them.
Great.
SAMUEL VOLCHENBOUM:
Thanks, Scott.
MICHAEL HOWELL:
Thank you, Scott.
So we're going to try
and share a little bit
about how we look at
this as physicians,
as folks in the
health care sector,
and as people who use large data
sets to try and make discovery.
And we're also going to try
and share some things where
we feel like there
may be problems
around de-identification that
we're hopeful will get solved
in the next few years.
And so where we're
going to start with is,
yeah, we're a couple of
doctors who are up here,
and I suspect several people are
wondering what conference you
think we're at.
We actually think that cloud
storage and de-identification
are important.
We think they're critical to
improving the pace of discovery
in health care, and we're
going to try and convince
you of that.
We're going to try
and convince you
that it's important to the
kind of research that we do.
And at the end of
the next 15 minutes,
we think you'll agree with that.
So I'm a doc.
I'm an ICU doc.
I have some grants to
study things like this.
It is important for
me to say that I
sit on a couple of committees
that provide advice
to the federal government.
The things I will talk about
are my opinions, not theirs.
But I do want you to
know that I'm an ICU doc.
I'm a critical care doc.
That influences how
I think about things.
It's a specialty most
people have never heard of.
We're the specialty that cares
for you if your risk of dying
is very high in
the next 24 hours.
I'm the chief quality officer
of the University of Chicago,
which is a moderate-sized
health system in the Midwest.
I work with what,
for health care,
are reasonably sized data sets.
And I've experienced both
good care and horrible care
perpetrated on my
family and feel a need
to try and make that better.
SAMUEL VOLCHENBOUM: So
I'm San Volchenboum.
I'm at the University
of Chicago.
And I just wanted to point out
a few things about the work
that I do.
So I have received and
I do receive funding
from the government for
some of the work that I do.
And those grants
are disclosed here.
I'm also a co-founder
of a company called
Litmus Health which is
building an analytics platform
to collect mobile data
for clinical trials.
So that work has given me
an interesting perspective
into how commercial
entities have
to think about privacy
of data, and I'll
try to bring some of
that to the talk today.
I have sat on a few
government committees.
The ones that are
mostly relevant
are things around building
data standards for things
like mobile devices
and for how we collect
data for clinical trials.
My day job is that I'm trained
as a pediatric oncologist.
So I take care of kids with
cancer and blood diseases.
I spend most of my time
running the Center for Research
Informatics at the
University of Chicago, which
is a 40-person group
providing informatics support
to the division.
My training is mostly in
medicine and molecular biology,
but I took a detour
to get a degree
in biomedical informatics.
And so that's how my three
worlds come together now.
And what I really try
to do is to figure out
how we can take data and
how we can democratize it
so that people can use
it to study and improve
health outcomes.
MICHAEL HOWELL: So we're going
to start with a question,
and we're going to come back
to this a little bit later
in the talk.
And the question is just this.
What is the difference
between a heart
attack and a cardiac arrest?
It turns out that actually
most people don't know this.
95% of people who have a heart
attack in the United States
today survive.
And cardiac arrest is the
recognition that you are dead,
and so it is a somewhat
more serious condition.
And we're going to come
back to the question of,
wouldn't you like
to know it's coming
so that you can prevent it?
And we're going to
try and show you
how we've used data
to address that
at the University of Chicago.
We do want to point out some
things about health care
that may be different than
other areas that use data.
The first is what the
office looks like.
And so this is the
picture of an ICU
that Google legal would
allow me to take a look at.
But if you look at
this here, there
are one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12 continuous
infusion IV pumps.
You can see that this
child is actually
intubated, on life support,
on mechanical ventilation.
There are number of other
monitors and things.
There's a $10,000 bed.
There's two tubes invading
the thoracic cavity here
to keep the lung open.
And oh, yeah, there's a
patient in the middle of that.
What we don't talk about is
that each of these devices
generate data.
The data are not aggregated
in a standard way.
They're not stored
They're not joined
in a standard way.
And all of this happens
in an environment
that is chaotic and
difficult to influence, even
with the world's
fanciest algorithms.
Our instant messaging queue may
also look different than yours.
These devices, which many
of you will recognize
from history books,
are wired directly
into our adrenal glands.
And they come across with these
things like, "Hi, Dr. Howell.
Can you come see
patient so and so?
Suctioning blood from
the airway and GI tract.
Now on as much oxygen as
it's possible to give.
Thanks, Sarah."
Our residents and trainees are
very polite at the University
of Chicago.
Or "Hi, Dr. Howell.
Just took over care for
this patient in the ICU.
Significant
respiratory distress.
Anesthesia coming to
start life support.
Think she would benefit
from thrombectomy," which
means having her chest cut
open, her pulmonary artery
incised, and a clot taken out.
And so those things are
disruptive to workflow
when you're trying
to plan your day,
but they also represent a
piece of absolutely critical
information that is stored
and analyzed nowhere.
SAMUEL VOLCHENBOUM:
So one of the things
that I'm hoping that you'll
be convinced of today
is that the way we think
about privacy in health care
is potentially different than
the way people that are not
in health care think about it.
The things that we
ask of our patients
are very, very personal.
And Michael takes care
of patients in the ICU.
I take care of
families with children
with cancer, many of
whom go to the ICU.
And the things we
ask of our patients
are things we do at the
worst times in their life.
And you can imagine that we're
asking them to discuss things
about death, things
about struggles
they're having at home.
Think about the things that
you'll discuss with your doctor
without thinking twice,
things about pregnancy,
about psychiatric illness.
It's incredible
the kinds of things
we'll share with our
health care provider.
And we want to do that
with the assumption
that those data are
going to remain private,
and that if our health
care data are shared,
they're done so in a way
that respects that privacy.
I'm going to show a
couple examples of people
that had really good
intentions about sharing data,
but that when they
published their data,
they did so in a way
that actually exposed
patients' medical records
and invaded their privacy.
This is a landmark paper
from about 15 years
ago from Latanya Sweeney that
actually focuses on k-anonymity
like Scott was referring to.
And here are two data
sets that they were
able to get their hands on.
The data set on the
left is medical data
that was released
with good intentions.
Whoever released
this data set felt
that this was going to
be data that was private,
that wasn't going to give
up anybody's privacy.
They had things like their
diagnosis, procedures
they had, and then three
seemingly innocuous items--
their zip code, their
birthday, and their gender.
On the right is a voter
registration list which they
requested which was
publicly available that
had a bunch of things, seemingly
innocuous-- name, address,
their party
affiliation, but also
had zip code, birthday, and sex.
And I don't think
it's really difficult
to see that if you were to
combine those two data sets,
you could match on those three.
And what they were
able to do was
to identify many of the
patients in this set,
including the governor
of Massachusetts
at the time whose data was here.
Again, these folks
had good intentions
that published these data.
But when you looked into
the sets they published,
they were able to expose
some of the privacy.
This, I think, is a
fascinating example.
So this was a paper
that was published
showing an influenza outbreak.
This is Boston, and
each of the red dots
is a site of an influenza
outbreak in Boston.
And what the authors
hoped to do in this study
was be able to understand
where the sites of influenza
were so they could
track the outbreak.
And so they published
this in a paper.
And this research group at
Harvard took this set of data.
And when I teach this,
I say, how would you
solve this problem?
And almost always somebody
raises their hand and says,
I would just put a
Google map on top of it.
And of course, that's what
this research group did.
They overlaid a
Google map on top.
And very quickly, they
were able to identify
80% of the dots on the
map to the exact address.
And when they
relaxed the radius,
they were able to identify 100%
of the people in the study.
So an incredible
invasion of privacy,
completely
unintentioned, seemingly
innocuous to put dots on a map.
And when I teach
about this, we talk
about things like, how
would you obscure the data?
And students will say, well,
you would shift everything
by 10 feet in some
random direction,
and that would do it.
And yes, that would do it
in the middle of Boston.
But if you shift everybody
10 feet in South Dakota,
you're going to move somebody
from their house to their barn,
and then you won't protect
anybody's anonymity--
no offense to South Dakota.
But that's the point
here is that it's
hard to do these problems.
You have to know the
population you're studying.
As has been mentioned
in other talks here,
there are a lot of regulation
around sharing data.
This is the simplified version
of the government's take
on how we have to protect data.
And what I want to
get across to you
is that there's a
financial penalty here
which is not cheap.
It's $50,000 per violation.
So if somebody
loses a spreadsheet
with a bunch of patients' data,
it could run up in the millions
very quickly.
And we're talking about data
over hundreds of thousands
of patients.
But there's also what we used to
call the "above the fold" risk.
Back when people
read newspapers,
we had this concept that when
something was really bad,
it would show up
on the front page
and you would see it on
the stack of newspapers.
The current version
of that is the wall
of shame that's maintained by
the Health and Human Services
which actually will
publish anybody that has
a breach of over 500 patients.
So you will end up on
here if you have a breach.
And HHS now is
tweeting out whenever
they post a new breach.
And so you will get
tagged in their tweet.
And you can now find
yourself on the wall of shame
if you do this.
So the risk is
actually very high,
both from a financial
perspective as well as
a reputational risk.
HIPAA is the set of rules that
governs how we share data.
It came out of the Recovery
and Reinvestment Act.
And they've defined
18 identifiers
of things you have to remove
to make it de-identified.
And there's things you would
expect-- name, address, email
address, and so forth.
But just to make sure
that they got everything,
they added this one
at the end here called
"any other unique
identifying number."
And I think the last talk
mentioned something about this
too in the previous
session, that it
can be any sort of
something that could
be used to identify the person.
And so you have to
really be careful
as you share data that
if you just strip out
these things that are
on this page here,
that might not be enough.
And we'll come back to that
toward the end of the talk.
So one of the things to think
about in health care data
is that it's
distributed everywhere.
And that's actually
the dirty secret
that people don't talk about.
If you think about all the
places your health data are,
they're everywhere.
This was highlighted
during the election when
there was these calls to
release the full medical record
for the presidential candidates.
Everybody wanted to
see the full record,
and they were probably
imagining some stack of papers
that was the full record.
But as you've seen just
in the short talk so far,
the full record includes
electronic health record data,
even data that you're
finding on pagers, data
that you're finding from pumps.
It could be
scattered everywhere.
And the interesting
quote from this article
that the author wrote, he
wrote, "Her medical records
are in bits and pieces, in
doctors' offices, filing
cabinets, hospital
records departments,
and hard-to-access computers.
Just like yours, probably."
And I would challenge anybody
to come up with all the spots
that their medical
record exists,
all the way down to the
grammar school office
where your vaccination
record is probably
sitting from years ago.
So your data are
scattered everywhere.
So what do we do about this?
We want to get the data into a
place where we can analyze it,
and we can do this
safely and with good
protection of privacy.
We need to fill up a
warehouse with data.
So at the University of Chicago,
the way we've approached this
is to--
we call it getting our
hands dirty with the data.
We have a group that I run
called the Center for Research
Informatics.
The guys that work for
me, I call them data
wranglers because
they get in there,
they learn about the
data, they model the data,
they make sure that
we're understanding
what's coming through as we take
data from the hospital systems.
And we built what we think is
a very well organized, clean
warehouse where when
you want to request data
on a particular disease, we
can get at the data in a way
that you have assurances
about the quality of the data
you're getting.
And I think one of the exciting
things about collaborating,
working with Scott and
working with the Google team,
is that we have a mutual
expectation about the quality
of the data and the
quality of the analysis
that's going to come out of it.
MICHAEL HOWELL:
So the other piece
to think about
with health care is
that it may be organized
differently than you think.
And the one study that I'll show
you today that someone else did
is how much R&D is done in the
health care delivery system.
When we think about
the health care system,
we think about biotech and
pharma and other areas.
But, in fact, the health
care delivery system
spends less than 1% of revenues
on R&D. The food and beverage
industry spends
fivefold more on R&D
than the health care
delivery system does today.
And that is, in some ways,
one of the crippling problems
of modern American health
care is that we're not
organized in that way.
And so one of the things
that we've attempted to do--
and we'll show you how this
plays out in a little bit--
is reorganize in a way where
the folks doing operations
in health care and the
folks doing research
don't live in different places.
We call that our
Center for Healthcare
Delivery Science and Innovation.
And it's one of the
things that lets
us work on really interesting
collaborations that impact
patients today, not 40
years in the future.
I am going to return
and try and give
an example of this in
action because why do we
care about data?
We do care about-- data
helps us get more efficient.
It helps us make margin.
It helps us reduce waste.
But it also impacts real
people in the real world.
And we'll give you two examples
of how we've done that.
So we said, what's the
difference between a heart
attack and a cardiac arrest?
95% of people with a
heart attack survive.
Cardiac arrest is the
recognition that you are dead.
And CPR doesn't work 80%
of the time, unlike on TV.
And so the University
of Chicago has
a long history of
excellence in cardiac arrest
research starting more
than a decade ago,
and with a team led by Matt
Churpek and Dana Edelson,
has been doing
predictive work in how
is it you would figure out who
would have a cardiac arrest
or develop critical illness
before that happens.
In the end, they did
a five-hospital study
with more than a quarter
million patients.
And I'm a predictive
modeler at heart.
This thing warms--
it warms my heart.
It's a 27-dimensional model.
It's got spline terms,
the whole nine yards.
And if you like
areas under the curve
as a way of assessing
how useful a model is,
this is today the
best predictive model
for cardiac arrest on the planet
developed in our patients.
But at the end of this, what
do these researchers have?
They have a paper published
in a journal affecting
no patient anywhere.
And so we've been
able to take this.
We have an enterprise
services bus architecture
at the University of
Chicago, turned this live,
and see over and above our
usual methods for responding.
We've seen a 20% reduction
in cardiac arrest
in about a year and a half span
after implementation of this.
That's a pretty clever thing
that we've been able to do,
and it's gotten some news
about how we've taken things
from the data warehouse,
from the Center for Research
Informatics, turned it into
something in the real world.
But there's another
interesting question
that now we can attack.
And it's actually
the question of,
can critical illness
be contagious?
So imagine that
you're hospitalized.
And it's a 10-bed unit, and
you're in the third bed,
or your mom's in the
third bed, or your brother
or your daughter.
And what happens if
the person in bed six
gets sick and needs the ICU
or has a cardiac arrest?
What happens to you?
Is the risk contagious?
And so if you thought
for a minute about how
you would study that, it's
actually a really difficult
problem to sort out.
And so we took about
90,000 patients' data,
time-ordered them, broke
them down into time blocks,
ran the 27-dimensional
multivariable model, sorted
out a zillion other
factors, and we
we're able to answer the
question of this, that,
in fact, yeah, if that
person has [? crumps ?]
and goes to the ICU,
for the next six hours,
your risk of developing
critical illness
goes up by 18% after
extremely careful control
for how sick you are.
And if two people
have that happen,
then the risk goes up by 54%.
And so now we're
attempting to turn
that live into,
how do we actually
deal with and adjust with that?
But these are examples
of the reasons
that we care so much
about the quality of data,
how we get the data
sorted, and then
how we begin to
be able to use it.
But privacy protection is
critical to making discoveries
like this.
We can't do it without it.
And it's really hard
to do privacy well
while making discoveries
that still save
lives if you're moving
outside your own institution.
And so we've said health
care data may be a little bit
different.
Privacy in health care may
be a little bit different.
Health care may not have R&D
as you would recognize it,
and that privacy protection
is critical to discovery.
And so we are really
excited about the changes
that have been happening
over the past few years.
We are really good on our
own at using discrete data
for predicting things.
We've been doing
that for a while.
It's not easy, but we've been
sorting out how to do it.
But today, we're beginning
to be able to think about how
we use the whole electronic
health record, including
the notes that doctors and
nurses and others write.
And one of the
problems is if you're
trained like I am,
as an epidemiologist,
as a health care
researcher, once you
get to 400, 500, 600 variables,
my models don't work.
But if we start using
free-text notes,
there are really new
challenges that are hard.
SAMUEL VOLCHENBOUM: OK,
so hang in there now.
I'm going to take
you through a couple
examples of some of
the challenges of using
free-text notes.
And I think they're
going to highlight
what we're so excited about
when it comes to collaborating
with Google on trying
to think about how
to do de-identification
of free-text notes
and how to do this analysis
over large sets of patient data.
This is an example of a
couple of notes on a patient.
The note says Mr. Smith is a
65-year-old man with weight
loss admitted on August 1.
Mr. Smith lives with
his sister, Jane.
And there's a family history
that Jane had tuberculosis
diagnosed in February.
So if you're seeing
this guy, he's
got this weird,
unexplained weight loss
and he's living with
somebody with tuberculosis,
you immediately start thinking,
could there be a connection?
Well, if we tried to
de-identify this information
using standard
redaction, we'll take out
the names and the exact dates.
And we're basically
left with blank
is a 65-year-old man
with weight loss admitted
sometime last year.
Blank lives with
his sister, blank.
And blank had tuberculosis
diagnosed sometime.
Useless, right?
Like, that doesn't
tell us anything.
Well, we can do a little
bit smarter than that
and we can actually
instead take the note,
and we can take out
the name, but we
can preserve the admit date.
So we can say that so-and-so
is a 65-year-old man admitted
with weight loss on some date.
And now we can use
the colors to say,
well, so-and-so lives with
his sister, another person,
and that other person
had tuberculosis,
and there's a
relationship there.
So this removes the
HIPAA identifiers
and it satisfies the
de-identification,
but still, the computer's
not telling us,
which is painfully
obvious to everybody who's
looking at this is,
yeah, something else
could be going on,
but I really think
that you should
think about he might
have got TB from his sister.
So this is an example of a
relatively simple heuristic
for a human to come up
with, but a difficult text
problem for a computer
to solve if you
want to maintain privacy.
So why is de-identification
in health care a hard problem?
Well, it's hard for
several reasons.
One is that we're trained to
think that we need to connect
the data with the outcomes.
And for discrete data, that
can be relatively easy.
But with free text,
it can be much more
difficult to know what the data
are, the discrete data that's
in the text, and what
the outcomes are.
We must remove the
HIPAA identifiers,
including the dates.
And in practice, when we do this
with discrete data, like blood
pressure and heart rate,
it's easy to remove
any of the HIPAA identifiers.
But as we move into free text,
it becomes very difficult
and you need a high-performance
environment to do this.
When we were first thinking
about doing this collaboration,
we thought, how long
would it take us
to de-identify our 20
million text notes?
And the first feedback
I got from my team,
that even on our
high-performance environment,
it would take us
six months to do it.
So I have a relatively complex
example to take us on out,
but I think it's
important and try
to hang in there
with me because I
think this is very illustrative
of the opportunity here.
So here's Frank Jones.
He's an 85-year-old man
here for his annual checkup.
He's been doing well
but recently was
forced to move from his
home in Batavia, Illinois
to Elgin due to
insufficient funds.
His eldest son,
Craig, was recently
killed in an
automobile accident.
Mr. Jones' remaining seven
children all live in Illinois.
Mr. Jones' orthopedic
surgeon, Dr. Reeves,
has been concerned about his
leg following his amputation
last year for diabetes.
But overall, he reports
no new medical issues.
OK, so there's a lot
of identifiers there.
So let's just redact out
the identifiers, his name.
And you're left with this note
that takes out all the names.
And there aren't any
dates in here, right?
And there aren't any addresses,
and there's no full zip code.
So this note, by all
accounts and purposes,
would look to be
de-identified, right?
But if you think back to
the k-anonymity lecture
we had before from
Scott, there's
something wrong with
this note because I
would argue that it's not been
de-identified appropriately.
So what identifiers
remain in this note?
Well, I would argue that
being an 85-year-old man
in a small town in Illinois
is not a very anonymous thing.
The fact that his son was killed
in a car accident; the fact
that he is an amputee; the fact
that he has eight children,
now seven children--
I would say that
all of those things
reduce this person's
k-anonymity number very low
so that this note is
actually quite identifiable.
So if we're left with looking
at all these identifiers,
why don't we just take them out?
All right, so
here's the note now.
I would argue now that this
note is pretty much useless.
We've taken out all
the meaning, and we're
left with a bunch of
Xs in here, and there's
no meaning in the note.
I think this is the part
where it gets really cool.
So wouldn't it be
cool, really, if we
used the power of
all the information
that a company like Google
has at its fingertips to,
in real time, think about,
what is the age distribution
in small town Illinois?
Is it safe to have an
85-year-old called out here?
Do we have to change that?
What about the fact that he
had a son killed in an accident
or that he's an amputee?
Google can check to see,
was that in a public record
somewhere?
Was there a newspaper
article about it?
Is there a publicly available
obituary that says this?
What about the fact that
he has a huge family?
Is that a common thing
in central Illinois?
Do we need to
change that as well?
And in real time, you could
take this note, actually,
and turn it into something that
does some of this obscuring
by changing the names.
Maybe you could change
the age a little bit.
But if you changed
the age, you want
to do it in a way that maintains
the information in the note.
There's an amazing array
of different things
that we could
consider if you think
about the power of all the
other reference data that
lives underneath the hood.
So de-identification is a
huge problem for research
because we need so much data
to study rare phenomenon,
like the kind that Michael
talked about, looking
for patients going to the ICU.
We needed 90,000 patients
to pick up even the smallest
amount of signal.
So, ideally, you would do
this for many hospitals,
and we would sort of require
you to collaborate and to share
data.
And to do that,
you're going to have
to standardize the data
while de-identifying it
and satisfying all the
different privacy boards
that you're not going to do
anything that compromises
the patients' privacy.
So that's why we're
here today, and that's
why we're so excited.
We're really looking forward
to this collaboration
because we're going to
understand how to use and study
sensitive data at large scale.
There's a lot we have
to do, and there's
a lot we're going to have
to do to get this done.
We're going to
have to figure out
how this de-identification
process makes research
more difficult. What is
the spectrum of, as you
de-identify things?
Does it make research
harder to do?
When is HIPAA not enough?
I showed you that
note before and I
argued that we removed
all the HIPAA identifiers,
but you would say HIPAA
is not enough there.
We need to consider the other
ways you can identify people.
So can these new
approaches maintain privacy
while preserving the research
value of the information?
And finally, what tools
can privacy boards
use to protect patients?
Right now, whenever our
IRB has a tough question,
they turn to Michael and me
and say, is this good enough?
And I would think there's
a better set of tools
that privacy boards
can start to use
to standardize how we
think about privacy
protection for patients.
So we really think that better
de-identification and better
analytics tools is going
to speed up health care
discoveries and is
really going to help
improve patient outcomes.
by letting us study these
enormous large sets of data.
So that's why
we're very excited.
Here's some of the groups that
have helped make this possible
at University of Chicago.
And if we have time, hopefully,
for Scott and Michael
and myself, we can
answer some questions.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]